elle dit que ce corps étranger enfin la
marque a dit que ce corps étranger
provenait des salades vertes
au final c'est dégueulasse alors
ça en Amérique il fermait les millions
[Applaudissements]
par exemple toute notre santé
alimentaire qui est catastrophique on
parle de scandale en scandale et les
pizzas on va pas citer les marques les
pizzas les œufs en chocolat il y a tout
et en fait en France vous avez 5800
agents au total pour tout contrôler
c'est impossible bordel total et chez
nous ça passe mais on bras de la santé
des gens et il y a des drames qui se
passent moi je pense pas que c'est le
manque de tu dis 5008 moi je pense que
5800 personnes ça suffit pour contrer
tous les restaurants c'est juste les
sanctions faut vraiment expliquer aux
gens que vous nous donnez à manger vous
êtes responsable de notre de notre
nourriture on peut mourir à cause de
vous des sanctions quand tu vois